joining us right now the Academy
award-winning actor Matthew McConaughey
back here on the Rich Eisen show how are
you Matthew I'm doing good I'm sitting
in my own throne with my initials over
my head well dion is sitting in the
state of Texas you know I mean like
that's the way I guess everybody from
the state of Texas runs right
[Laughter]
unbelievable dion is one of a con hey
man this PSA is a beautiful thing how
did it come about yeah I mean so you
know me like everybody sitting at home
the last five weeks and I'm sitting
there trying to say hey what's what's
the message didn't need to get out and
win and I mean a month ago it was clear
we need to stay at home I'm in about two
and a half weeks ago came very clearly
needed merit where mass I put out this
thing in English and played this
character Bobby bad deep doe you can
call me Bobby B about wearing bandanas
and then my the mayor of our city Austin
said look the Hispanic communities not
getting the message to wear the mask so
I did some research town state in the
United States and worldwide notice that
that was happening all over the world
that spanish-speaking beauties weren't
getting the message so I said who would
they listen to they might listen to me
speak in my broken Spanish but I need to
find somebody else that could speak it
better to me that they would look up to
so I met Canelo
years ago at the Golden Gloves event
called him and he said he was in I wrote
it directed him over text and that's
what we got no kidding
okay by the way again I'm not fluent it
doesn't sound broken to me it sounds
like you're pretty pretty fluent in the
language yeah yeah no I would kind of be
in the kind of falsely modest oh no I do
like it so so is that it's at a one-take
situation with you in Spanish at the one
takes it down Canella it was too
textured Canela because he was in San
Diego and I had to talk to his cameraman
who was holding his iPhone over there
just about some framing but other than
Canelo was one take as well so you were
directing him from like you're live
you're sitting there you say okay move
this over move that over and then and
Canelo Alvarez just stuck the landing
and then you got a PSA absolutely yeah
so hopefully that message gets out it
was fun to do and there we go found
another place to put just keep
but did it in Spanish just solo to get
in and we're seeing right now on the
screen a mask that says just keep living
as well yeah across my back exactly and
then the JK Living Foundation JK live in
foundation.org founded by you and
Camilla yeah so to date you're providing
meals and also laptops because again the
number of kids would depend on meals
through school and obviously
homeschooling for some is not simple at
all because they now don't have the
equipment in order to connect to schools
so I wonder how you got involved in that
Matthew well I mean a lot of the
students that we serve through our
foundation
are in these title one schools and a lot
of them are depending on some I'm two
meals a day from the school I mean that
was that was two of their three meals a
day they were getting from the school so
now they can't go to school they were
missing two meals so we're providing as
many meals to them and their families as
we can I mean the other thing a lot of
them you know not they're out of school
they want to continue learning they
don't have the means to they didn't have
a laptop or they didn't have a hot spot
so we started working up some funds and
got some laptops out and got some hot
spots where they didn't happen JK Living
Foundation org to get involved in that
and and help out or see some more and
then the all-in challenge I'm seeing so
much about that you're involved in that
too right yeah yeah that's nothing about
about feeding the people that need it
you know right now yeah I've got a I'm
putting up a game Dexter's down here in
Austin Texas and Darrell K royal
Memorial Stadium once this college
football season kicked off right who
wants to come to a town here spend the
day with me and my family go to a game
long horn game we got to tailgate and
pregame we got you during the game in
the box come on down the field in the
sidelines we can get a bird's-eye view
or a man's eye view of the game Thomas
and we'll have a great time know what
I'm off what are you what do you like
during a game Matthew are you are you
how intense are you into the action so
people who are going to be bidding on
this know what they're getting
ya know that know this if anyone's
bidding it if you want to take any any
pictures or talk about you know movies
or anything other than what's happening
on the field that's why we're going to
get there early we'll get that done
because once the kickoff starts I'm
breaking a sweat I'm into it I'm not I'm
not a great conversation about anything
other than the game while the game's
happening so it's it's game time
not time as a flat circle that's the
conversation essentially that's what
you're saying over and over and over for
about three and a half hours it's game
time so that's the Minister of Culture
talking essentially not the Academy
award-winning actor Matthew McConaughey
talking is what you're saying
a hundred percent it would it would not
be good culture doing it during a
long-gone football game and a long one
fan to be having your mind or mouth
elsewhere other other than on the game
pretty much so in terms of that man oh
man I I can't obviously the virus has
its own schedule and that's what we're
talking about here with your PSA and
again JK live in foundation.org and
you're all in challenge but man that
first game when it happens I mean I know
again you're a minister culture you
don't take this stuff for granted but
maybe we all have I can't wait what that
will be like that's going to be insane
that's first it is gonna be I mean
collectively been especially is in the
United States I mean it for football for
our American football it is going to be
collective one of the day will be
remembered on many calendars for the
rest of many lives when our first game
comes back and then you know the
question is what are we gonna it's all
in the air you may know more than I do
right when do you are we gonna play
games there's gonna be some sort of fans
I mean there will be televised there are
we going to have games where hundred
thousand capacity yeah stadiums are only
taking as many fans that can sit six
feet apart I don't know are they going
to provide mass what are those going to
look like obviously collegiately they
got to sell tickets and everyone wants
the thing their games to go on
but IIIi don't know I mean we're all up
in the air on that right now are they
going to play without fans but then
televise it or are we going to find some
something here in the next few months
where we go we got the vaccine we're
clear let's roll that would be obviously
the best option I think it'll probably
be without fans Matthew to start but
you're not wrong and and if baseball
starts first apparently you know no fans
but the dugout will be the players won't
be in the dugout they'll be in the
stands six feet apart you know like like
they're literally talking about this
like it's all up in the air essentially
we're yeah we are calling audibles
sweetie I don't you know at the line of
scrimmage on all of this
I mean look no one wants to play with
that fans but it's still a game the game
can still be played you know what do you
lose you besides losing the chance of
being there as a player in whatever so
said game the competition still there
the rules are still the same you don't
know you no longer have a home field
advantage or or you know a deficit for
playing away but I think you know that
would be worthy to go play the game you
can have boy talk about people watching
whoever's got the rights to the games
right that networks happy no doubt about
that and the few minutes I have left
with you let's talk a little bit of
professional football I'm sure so many
people Matthew who are quite you clearly
and for good reason with with Texas
football when they start assuming you're
a Cowboys fan
what's the looks that you get when you
reveal that you actually root for the
Washington Redskins what is that one
closed eye when they're cheek raises up
and they're like and then they go when
you're watching you're four years old
watching westerns with your dad and you
find yourself rooting for the Indians
versus the Cowboys and then when your
favorite foods hamburgers and you got a
middle linebacker number 55 who's now in
the Hall of Fame called Chris tan burger
when you're four years old man your guy
that's already two for two and then I
will say this at eight years old I was
in Texas Stadium made for three-hour
drive from Long Beach
access to what was the Cowboys use plain
text Stadium you know this a lot of
people may not before a GMT yesterday
and the [ __ ] game I'm I show up I'm
on the sidelines at eight years old
painted burgundy shirtless shoeless with
the headdress on and a chamois remember
the chamois you dry your car with sure I
had a [ __ ] a chamois um like roped
around my waist loincloth chamois and I
remember I thought I could go naked just
like the Indians like like like I was my
mom said no you gotta wear your baby
deeds man you got away now the Red King
games that was the only reason I could
stay up past 8:30 at night if the
Redskins played on Monday Night Football
this is the reason I'd get in trouble in
church because I church would go to
12:30 and I'd have to sneak out in the
car put on Pat Summerall calling the
game and when Dallas was playing the
Redskins on the AM radio oh yeah and I
just took the penalty I said you can
ground me that was a 15-yarder Matthew
I'm sure he doesn't know yeah I mean I
got to stay in the game but we went
backwards yes yes well man did you ever
get to an RFK game did you ever get to a
game in RFK did you ever hit oh yeah I
was at the last game at RFK the first
game of jack kent cooke and the first
game at FedEx Field I have a mason jar
with Burgundy's soil that I went down on
the field an Alaskan bar FK and pulled
up a foot five 12 inch by 12 inch chunk
and I ran off the field with ya so what
do you think of the current state I mean
chase Young was the second overall pick
in the draft that went down last week
yeah and Ron Rivera is a new head coach
there what do you think well that look I
like where we're heading
we've needed we've needed to get our
compass
corrected here for a while and you know
the work
cultures thrown around a lot like what's
your culture what's your culture and
everybody you know could look over the
past however many years and say wow look
at you know New England's that the
pinnacle of that of how they run that
system no matter who you are
individually you're coming into
Belichick system how they run that
organization we've needed to get a comes
right Ron Rivera
I love the higher I love his mindset I
love how he is changing the culture I
believe Dan Snyder's really found a
position now to say look I'm the owner
let nom I'm truly back off and let the
person I hired do the job the right way
we got to change we have we need to make
a change and I think we're really now on
our way you know we used to be one of
the great dynasties you know in a
championship dynasty and mind you
there's so few dynasties now but this is
a chance for us to get back in that
conversation it's not going to happen
immediately either I don't think I think
we are now saying hey we're gonna build
a dynasty again inhale Redskins Matthew
HTT are as they say right hey hashtag
Matthew always enjoy our chats
I love the PSA again people can check it
out certainly on JK live in
foundation.org where you can learn more
about the meals and laptops that Matthew
and his wife are making sure that kids
are are equipped with your all-in
challenge where you can go hang out at a
game but talk only about movies and TV
before you pregame that's a preview
conversate may I have time that's fine I
always enjoy our chats Matthew your and
thanks all y'all doing you know I think
you did stuff too oh I appreciate that
and your team are all pros my wife and I
are friends at Shannon rothenburg and
your team that is always great with with
ours your first rate Thank You Matthew
keep it up you can't you gotta that's
Matthew McConaughey Academy Award winner
love that guy man he's a great
storyteller
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here